BRIAN CUSACK: I'm here today
with Jim Koch, the founder
and chairman of Boston Beer
Company that you guys all know
was the brewer of Sam Adams.
He does have a new book out.
He's in his 32 year--
is that correct?
JIM KOCH: Yeah.
BRIAN CUSACK: Of brewing
Sam Adams beer and a number
of other different things.
You going to crack
one for me too, Jim?
JIM KOCH: If you want.
BRIAN CUSACK: Yeah.
JIM KOCH: I hate drinking alone.
BRIAN CUSACK: OK.
Well, you've got
about 110 people here
at some point they are going
to be drinking with you.
And maybe more that just
aren't here for this.
Thank you very much.
So I just want to start off
with a couple of questions
about authoring first.
And then we'll
get into the beer.
OK?
We'll get into the beer talk
and the Boston Beer story.
So I'm curious, Jim, in
the last several years,
I know-- I tried to start
counting last night-- I
think I know between five and
10 people-- five and 10 Boston
business people
who have published
books in the last couple
years about business.
And I just wondering what's
your-- what was your motivation
today or when you started
this project to write a book,
and what were you
trying-- what did
you want to contribute
to the business dialogue
or for folks like
this in your book?
And cheers by the
way, another book.
JIM KOCH: Cheers.
BRIAN CUSACK: OK.
JIM KOCH: I got better head.
Always a good thing.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm sorry.
I'm really sorry.
So I apologize.
It's a little weird for me
to be speaking to all of you,
realizing that I am the
stupidest person in the room.
But I've had 18 beers today.
Not full beers but
tasting and sampling
so maybe-- you all
may be smarter than me
but I've had more beer.
BRIAN CUSACK: Which might--
JIM KOCH: We'll see
how that works out.
BRIAN CUSACK: Which
might make you smarter.
JIM KOCH: We'll see.
BRIAN CUSACK: OK.
So I'm sorry, the question was,
what made me write the book?
BRIAN CUSACK: Yeah.
What motivated you to
write a book today or now.
JIM KOCH: Well, it
wasn't so much today.
I started working on it
three or four years ago.
I was actually
surprised at how much
work it is to actually
write a book as opposed
to ghost writing it or
something like that.
It was a lot of work, it was my
summer project for three years.
The motivations were, over 32
years I've had a lot of people
ask me, you know, Jim,
what did you learn?
You started something
in your kitchen,
whatever, helped create a
whole revolution in beer.
Did you learn anything from it?
It was kind of depressing
when I wrote it
because it's divided up into
chapters and each one of them
is kind of a story with
a lesson-- so something
that I learned-- and I
started Sam Adams 32 years ago
and there's like 40
chapters in the book.
I mean, do the math.
I only learned one thing a year.
That's not a lot
but it's all I had.
So that was one
reason I wrote it,
was to kind of put down on
paper what I had learned
and-- I didn't want it
to be a normal business
book because, frankly,
most business books,
they're ghost written and
they have one or two ideas
and then they stretch
them out to 180 pages
and they'd have been much
better as a five page "Business
Review" article because
that's what there is
and then there's one
idea and then they just
beat the thing to death.
And my experience
was not that way.
It wasn't a single big truth
but rather stories and lessons
from them.
And I don't know, I
guess, philosophically, we
have Plato and Aristotle
and for Plato knowledge
was almost mathematical,
Pythagorean, geometric,
everything that
was real knowledge
had to be universal and
necessary and constant.
And I don't think
business knowledge
is universal and
necessary and certain.
It's more contextual
and probabilistic
rather than A squared plus
B squared equals C squared.
So I wanted to approach business
learning in a more Aristotelian
way, that it's stories
and we learn by stories,
and knowledge is contextual
and probabilistic.
So that was one reason.
I guess the other reason was
so that my children would
know what I was doing
when I wasn't there.
BRIAN CUSACK: OK.
JIM KOCH: Missed
their soccer games
and their plays
and all that stuff.
Which anybody who
starts a business,
I don't want to make it too
beautiful and idealistic.
There's lots of
sacrifices and there's
a certain amount of pain
that comes with the territory
because you really have
to make trade-offs.
And so I wanted my children to
know what I was doing when I
should have been
there and wasn't.
BRIAN CUSACK: Have
they read the book?
JIM KOCH: Oh, yeah.
BRIAN CUSACK: And were
they pleased with what
you were doing?
What did they take from it?
JIM KOCH: They were like,
Dad, you swear too much.
[LAUGHTER]
And we'll see.
They will absorb it.
But to me, actually, also
did the auto book myself.
So I recorded every
word of that book
so that my grandchildren
could actually hear my voice.
BRIAN CUSACK: So there's a
legacy component to it as well.
JIM KOCH: You don't leave
behind that much in this world.
BRIAN CUSACK: Yeah.
So there's a legacy component.
Also, by using the
word Aristotelian,
you've elevated yourself
to the 25th percentile
of smarts in the room.
JIM KOCH: All right!
BRIAN CUSACK: All right?
JIM KOCH: I'm getting
closer, you guys.
BRIAN CUSACK: You're doing well.
JIM KOCH: I'm getting closer.
BRIAN CUSACK: Second--
JIM KOCH: I was going to say
stochastic but I don't really
know what it means.
I said probabilistic.
BRIAN CUSACK:
Neither do I. I would
have got to the 50th
percentile for that one.
What did you write on?
What kind of device?
JIM KOCH: Everyone has a dirty
little secret in this world.
BRIAN CUSACK: Do you
have a typewriter?
JIM KOCH: My dirty little
secret is I can't type.
I really-- I mean, everybody
here grew up with typing and I
didn't.
I was in college-- I
made it through college
by always finding a girl
friend who could type.
That kind of worked.
And we-- at Boston Beer we
avoided email for as long
as possible and did
things off of voicemail.
Which has its own
special advantages,
and I'm not sure
which is better,
but email has clearly
triumphed over voicemail.
So I-- the book was
either transcribed
into a voice recorder and
then typed out or handwritten.
So I wrote a lot
of it on legal pads
with different--
because it was a--
which is a somewhat sensual
experience, a tactile
of actually writing
something and actually caring
what the letters look like.
BRIAN CUSACK: As is
reading the book itself,
is the actual sensation of
the pages in the modern world.
You know, the book
itself is this tactile.
JIM KOCH: Yeah.
And there was a
guy here, I can't
remember what his first
name was, he was at MIT,
it was 10, 15 years ago--
something Negroponte.
BRIAN CUSACK: Nicholas.
Nicholas--
JIM KOCH: Nicholas.
OK.
BRIAN CUSACK: Yeah.
Nicholas Negroponte.
JIM KOCH: Right.
And he wrote a book
called "Being Digital"
and I remember reading
it and thinking,
this is pretty
interesting because he's
talking about being digital
and he wrote it in a book.
BRIAN CUSACK: Well, he--
JIM KOCH: And at the end
of the day I was like,
a book is pretty user-friendly.
BRIAN CUSACK: Sure it is.
JIM KOCH: It's actually
much more user-friendly
than a Kindle.
BRIAN CUSACK: And at
that point in time
it was probably going to reach
more people than any other form
[INAUDIBLE].
JIM KOCH: Still does.
More books, I believe, are
read as physical books than as
digital.
BRIAN CUSACK: Yeah.
JIM KOCH: Paper's
pretty user-friendly.
BRIAN CUSACK: Absolutely.
Now, I did read the book.
JIM KOCH: Good.
The book.
BRIAN CUSACK: I read the book.
JIM KOCH: The physical book.
BRIAN CUSACK: The physical book.
JIM KOCH: OK.
BRIAN CUSACK: And take
us back 33, 34 years
and just tell us the story.
I know it's really super
basic, but how'd it
start, why did it start?
JIM KOCH: Very good question.
And I'll give you sort of--
or go back to the beginning.
I was born, I was very small.
I got bitter as I got older.
BRIAN CUSACK: You went down to
the 10th percentile just now.
JIM KOCH: All right.
It feels very comfortable.
I grew up in Ohio-- in southern
Ohio-- and when I was 17
the letter came in
the mail that changed
the trajectory of my life
because I went to public school
in southern Ohio and I was
first kid from my high school
to go to Harvard.
And that was just-- I
go back to my reunions
and I realize how
important that was.
I came here, went
to Harvard College,
and then went to-- Harvard has
this masochistic program that
allows you to do a JD and an MBA
in four years instead of five.
So I started there.
So I started right
out of college
and went to this JD MBA program.
Did the first year of law
school, the first year business
school, and was just
sort of burnt out.
And I did something-- apparently
I'm the only one that's
ever done it-- I dropped out.
Just dropped out.
And left because I felt like--
I talk about it in "Quench Your
Own Thirst"-- but
I felt like, OK,
I was in this river that was
moving me along and the place
that it was going to go, which
was back then corporate America
or big law firms, I didn't
want either one of them.
And I didn't know how
to find an alternative
and I couldn't resist the
force of the river, so I said,
I got to get out of here.
So I dropped out,
worked odd jobs,
everything from Manpower--
you know, which was $2 an hour
stuffing shampoo bottles into
variety packs-- to [INAUDIBLE]
but mainly I worked
for something
called Outward Bound which
is experiential education.
And it taught me a great deal
about leadership because--
and it was-- well, you get
eight or 10 people, average age
early 20s, 28 days late-- take
them out in the wilderness,
28 days later you're supposed
to bring them all back.
And there's all these business
books about leadership
that are OK.
They're talking about
leadership in an office
and they're all important, but
what I got out of Outward Bound
was a different
kind of leadership.
It was out in the wilderness,
and most importantly,
if you made bad decisions you
had a decent chance, sooner
or later, somebody was
going to get killed dead.
And it actually happened
on a companion patrol
to mine where my
equivalent, the instructor,
made some bad decisions
and he killed a girl.
And it's no fun finding
bodies and bringing
them back-- they
begin to smell--
it's not a fun experience.
And it's a very
dramatic experience.
And that taught me
things about leadership
that you're not going to
learn at business school.
And some of them,
when I wrote the book,
I realized, wow, I learned a lot
of things from Outward Bound,
maybe more than I learned at
business school or law school.
And eventually, after
three and a half years,
I realized, OK,
this is not what--
I don't want to be
an Outward Bound
instructor for the
rest of my life,
I'm going to go back and
get finish my education.
Which I did and I
spent six years working
for Boston Consulting Group
back in the early days.
And after six years I
thought, OK, I like this,
it's challenging, there's a
lot of intellectual content.
It's a great job.
I had this beautiful office
on the 33 floor of 60 State
Street, it looked over the
harbor, you fly first class,
you stay at the--
all that stuff.
But I thought, is
this what I want
to do for the rest of my life?
And the answer was, no.
And then I realized,
well, the rest of my life
starts tomorrow,
so if I don't want
to do it for the
rest of my life,
I don't want to do it tomorrow.
And I went in and
I gave my notice.
I don't know what
I was going to do
but I knew that I didn't want
to work for a big company.
I've had this somewhat
unusual career experience--
I'm 67 now, had multiple jobs--
but one of the things I've
never had is a boss.
I've never had a boss.
And so I realized, I'm
a really bad employee.
There must be some reason
I've never had a boss.
I've avoided things
where you actually
have to come into
an office, work
in the same place every
day, and report to somebody.
And I didn't want to have that
at the time so I thought, well,
maybe I'll-- I'll
start my own company.
And this was in 1983, 1984.
Somewhat unusual.
I mean, we are now in
a much better culture,
but back then, there was no
fast company, no real culture
of entrepreneurship.
It was a somewhat-- there wasn't
much even of a venture capital
community at that point.
But it was just
starting to happen
and I thought about, well,
what do I want to do?
I looked at-- my experience
was-- once I quit my job,
ideas sort of flooded in.
And I guess I would
think about it
as, we're all kind
of radio recei--
we're all receivers and ideas
for businesses are out there.
They're like radio
frequencies and it's
a matter of not finding them,
it's a matter of tuning in.
And once you tune
in, there's lots
of stations playing and
lots of opportunities
and interesting
things you can do.
And Google has this
amazing culture
of encouraging that within
a corporate structure,
which in and of itself, is
a huge reinvention of how
organizations function.
And the opportunities
that are out there.
One of the things that I guess
I would hope people remember
is, we all live
in the status quo.
The status quo sucks.
The only reason the
status quo exists
is because nobody's figured
out how to make it better.
But somebody will.
Whatever element the
status quo there is,
somebody will eventually figure
out how to make it better.
And that was kind
of my mentality of,
I'm going to find something
where I can do that.
I have this peculiar
background-- family background,
I guess-- I am the sixth oldest
son in a row in my family
to be a brewer.
A brewer.
BRIAN CUSACK: Brewer.
JIM KOCH: My father
was a brewmaster,
my grandfather was a brewmaster,
my great grandfather,
my great great grandfather, my
great great great grandfather
were all brewmasters.
BRIAN CUSACK: In
the United States?
JIM KOCH: In the United States.
Before that in Germany.
And I don't really care.
I'm American.
Forget about Germany.
I just happen to be American
and I'm proud of it.
To me it's a better deal
than being a German.
That's just my
personal preference.
So I thought-- and there was
this sort of gravitational pull
about brewing.
And my dad discouraged me.
I told him, you know--
well, let's see,
the stimulus came from
reading an article that
was in "Inc. Magazine"
when they first started.
It was December,
I think, of 1983
and they wrote about a
brewery in San Francisco
called Anchor Brewing.
And they were an outlier.
When I was at BCG,
a lot of what we did
was find relationships
between one thing and another,
that bigger lowers
costs or, I don't know--
BRIAN CUSACK: Smaller is faster.
JIM KOCH: Smaller is faster, all
these general rules of business
that you would find.
And the problem with
the general rules
is they're the general rules
and most people know him.
So there's not really
much advantage there.
What was-- really
where the value added
was in the outliers,
the points off the line.
And it always fascinated me.
I'd draw these graphs and
you'd see the general rule
and you'd tell the client that.
But then I'd look at the points
that weren't on the line.
I remember in 1978, like in
building cars, volume per style
lowered costs for
virtually every auto
maker in the world
who wasn't Japanese.
And the Japanese had lower
cost, higher quality,
and shorter runs,
smaller volume per style.
Those outliers where
all the truth is.
So Anchor's-- Anchor Brewing was
an outlier and the truth hidden
in their being the outlier was
that volume and scale are not
necessary to be profitable
and successful if you offer
a unique, differentiated,
and higher quality product.
And so that was
essential insight
that started Sam
Adams was if I make
that-- if I make great beer
here in the United States,
somebody is going to drink it
and I can build a business out
of that.
Now, it's embarrassing to
go look at my business plan.
If I did write one,
it's not that long,
but it's got some graphs and
it back-- you all won't even
know this but they used to
have to print special log log
paper because you
couldn't do it with Excel.
There was no such thing.
So they were-- people printed
log log papers, semi log
papers so you could plot
logarithmic and semi
logarithmic relationships.
I did this business plan with
these kinds of things in it.
I thought I was really smart.
I looked at small scale brewing.
There was no craft brewing, the
term hadn't been invented yet.
There were just a handful of
wackos that we're doing this.
Bike mechanics, dope
smokers, odd balls
that were going into this.
And my business plan that
I raised my money on,
and it was-- I
raised $140,000 and I
had $100,000 myself-- was that
I would grow for five years,
reach 5,000 barrels of beer,
a million dollars in revenue,
eight employees, and I could
pay myself $80,000 a year,
which is probably $150,000
in today's dollars.
And I thought, if
I could just do
that, I would be a happy
man for the rest of my life.
BRIAN CUSACK: That was
your five year plan?
JIM KOCH: That was
my permanent plan.
BRIAN CUSACK: That was
your permanent plan.
[LAUGHTER]
JIM KOCH: Projection was 5,000
barrels, a million dollars,
I would plateau.
BRIAN CUSACK: OK.
So--
JIM KOCH: Didn't work out.
BRIAN CUSACK: So I don't want
to go through every chapter,
but-- so how about this.
At five years, where were you?
JIM KOCH: Well, let me think.
Let me put it this way.
We hit 5,000 barrels not in
five years but in five months.
BRIAN CUSACK: OK.
JIM KOCH: And we are
now over four million.
BRIAN CUSACK: Four
million barrels.
JIM KOCH: So I was off
by almost 1,000 to one.
But it was in the
right direction.
So it's OK to be wrong
as long as you're
in the right direction.
BRIAN CUSACK: Do
you actually think
there might be a lesson when you
look back at the simplicity--
not the accuracy of
your business plan
but the simplicity of
your business plan,
that there's a lesson in that?
JIM KOCH: Absolutely.
And it's an important
lesson because it
had a simple idea that clearly
had upside if I could do it.
And, in addition,
the truth-- and I
wrote it in the last
chapter of the book.
It was actually the only
chapter where I sat down,
wrote the whole thing straight
through in about an hour,
and the editor
didn't fuck with it.
So it's like the absolute
most sincere chapter.
But I had a chance
to think about,
what if I'd done my
business plan and no more?
Where would I be now?
And I realized, I'd
be just as happy.
Maybe happier.
Because my plan was I'd
have this little niche
business making great
beer, become a beacon
for quality brewing
in the United States,
and I wouldn't have to drag
my ass all over the country
and it wouldn't be
that complicated
and I could work 40
or 50 hour weeks.
And I realized,
had that happened,
I'd probably be just as happy,
maybe happier, than today.
BRIAN CUSACK: But who knows.
JIM KOCH: Who knows.
Can you tell us about
the name of the beer?
JIM KOCH: Sam Adams?
BRIAN CUSACK: Yeah.
JIM KOCH: OK.
I'll tell you the
real story because--
BRIAN CUSACK: And
what it almost was.
JIM KOCH: Well, there
was a couple of things.
My background was
in manufacturing.
I was a manufacturing
consultant so I
had no experience
with marketing,
I didn't really have
a great opinion of it.
In manufacturing it's all about
making a superior product,
and I believe that's
actually true with everything
that you do.
So I don't know what
to name the beer
and I had a whole bunch
of different names.
I thought of them.
My original one was to
call it what it was.
Because the recipe for
Sam Adams Boston Lager
came from my great
great grandfather's
brewery in St.
Louis where he made
this beer in the
1860s, '70s, and '80s,
kind of during the golden
age of American brewing
when American
brewers were making
rich, flavorful beer
that was winning awards
all over the world.
And I thought,
well, I'll call it
what it was originally called
which was Louis Koch Lager.
Now, unfortunately, my name
is German and it's spelled
K-O-C-H. And people are
prone to mispronounce that,
sometimes in an obscene way.
So somebody looked
at it and said, Jim,
you can't call it that.
I mean, particularly,
you've got it
in a 12 ounce long neck bottle.
People got to put
that in their mouth.
I just don't think
that's a good idea.
And that was a
lesson light in time.
Well, maybe that's not
something that people
want to put in their mouth
in that long neck bottle.
So I thought, OK, I'll
think of something else
and so I came up with a
bunch of different names,
including Samuel Adams.
But one of my original
investors was a marketing guy
and he's like, Jim, you can't
just come up with these names.
You don't know what you're
doing, you need a professional,
you need to find professionals
who can name your beer for you.
And I was like, well,
are there people
who make a living naming beers?
And he said, no, no, no, no,
get an ad agency, they'll do it.
And so I found this ad agency.
It was actually
three bartenders.
So I said, OK, I
like these guys.
And for, I don't know what
it was, two, three grand,
I was like, can you
come up with a name?
And I explained to them I want
an assertively American name.
I'm not trying to be a fake
European beer because there
were a lot of them back then.
Lowenbrau was brewed
by Miller and there
were a whole bunch of German
sounding-- Earl Langer
and even Michelob is a Bavari--
Bohemian brewing village.
So I want an assertively
American name
that would be a good bar call.
So they listened to
all this and understand
what I'm trying to do.
And then two weeks
later I come back
for-- I don't know if anybody's
been through an ad agency
presentation.
OK.
I hear the laughter.
So it's kind of
this kabuki theater
and they go through
this thing like,
oh, we heard
everything you said,
we listened, you wanted a name
that was assertively American
and a strong bar call,
et cetera, et cetera,
and we thought about this,
but that wasn't good enough.
And we thought about this
and that wasn't good enough.
And then we went back and we
did more work and we kept going,
and finally we came up--
we finally have the killer
name for your beer, Jim.
And it's like, oh, great.
What is it?
And you could almost
hear like this drum roll.
It was like, Jim, the perfect
name for your new beer
is Sacred Cod.
[LAUGHTER]
Right?
Love it?
That was it.
Apparently-- I was
like, sacred cod?
Sounds like sacred cow,
it's a stinky fish,
you're bringing a
religion into this.
I mean, I like beer but it's not
always a religious experience,
you're just trying to get laid.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, it's the state's
symbol of Massachu--
there is a sacred cod.
It hangs in the
state-- in Beacon Hill.
You might have seen it, right?
It's this really sort
of stupid gross looking
wooden plaque that is gilded
with gold leaf with this fish.
Because I guess the cod was
a big part of the economy
of Massachusetts in the 1600's.
We've forgotten about that.
So that was my experience
with marketing genius.
Even worse, I
hired them and they
were my ad agency for 10
years and they actually
did a whole bunch
of other good stuff.
But the sacred cod
thing was a bomb.
BRIAN CUSACK: OK.
That's what we-- but how'd
we get to where we are?
JIM KOCH: Oh.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
OK.
I forgot about that.
All right.
So I had this list of names.
It was like 300 names
that had come to me.
Because it took me a
long time to leave BCG,
some old clients
came back, I needed
to keep working and doing
the right thing for them.
And I finally left.
So I had hundreds of names.
I winnowed it down
to half a dozen,
and the ad agency-- Gere
and Hoffman Goranson--
they actually found somebody
who could do the names.
The Sam Adams name
actually on the label
came from-- it cost me
$400, it was a woman at BCG.
Now, this is going
to strike all of you
as petroglyphs, as
incredibly primitive.
But, in 1984, there
was no PowerPoint.
Presentations are called slides.
Right?
It's a complete anachronism.
Slides were either
35 millimeter slides
that went through a
projector or, simpler to do,
was acetates.
Essentially, the way slides
were made 30 years ago
was there were graphic
artists at a place like BCG
and they-- you'd make the
slide on graph paper, whatever
kind it was-- semilog,
linear, whatever--
and then an artist would
put tracing paper over that,
take this osmiroid pen, and
draw in the lines on it,
and then have these rub
off things for the dots
and this tape that would
make the actual line.
You probably remember this.
And then they'd put it
in a-- I hate to say it.
[LAUGHTER]
BRIAN CUSACK: Well, OK.
So if we're going there, who
was not born when any of this
was happening?
Raise your hand if
you were not born.
Yeah.
OK.
JIM KOCH: Oh, come on.
It's most of you.
So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
people were drawing them
with pens on acetate.
JIM KOCH: Yeah.
And then you would
take the tracing paper
and you would put it
on a copying machine,
and instead of paper you
would put these clear sheets.
And that would make your slide.
So there were these,
quote unquote,
artists who were
totally underutilized.
They'd gone to RISD or someplace
like that so were actually
very talented artists,
but they ended up
with this sucky job of
rubbing off lettre set
points onto tracing paper.
But there was a
whole bunch of talent
there so I went to--
there was one of them that
did what most of my slides-- her
name was Dale Hutchinson-- who
was a really talented artist,
just totally under utilized.
I said, Dale, will
you make my label?
And she did.
She charged me $400.
That was the original
Sam Adams label.
So I had that label and then
one that the ad agency had done,
and I had-- I had
six different names.
There was Sam Adams,
there was New World,
there was James Otis,
there was Liberty Tree,
there was Joy Street--
which is on Beacon Hill,
had a brothel in the old
days-- and Golden Oak.
I think those were the six.
This was my market research.
So I had a little six pack
and I went from bar to bar
and I would go in the bar,
I'd talk to the bartender
and I'd say, I'm going to
start a brewery in Boston.
He was like, what?
I'm going to start small
and I'm going to make a beer
and I don't know the name of it.
Would it be OK if I talk to
the people here in the bar?
And I didn't do it on Friday
nights, I'd do it in the week.
So I collected data.
That was my data.
I had like 200 data
points and the two winners
were Sam Adams and New World.
New World was the first
clipper ship ever built.
It was built in East Boston.
It was a beautiful ship crossing
the label, breaking the frame.
And those were the two winners.
And I couldn't decide,
and eventually I
had to because we had
to print the labels.
The beer was getting ready and
I just sort of closed my eyes
and I thought, what do
I want my beer to be?
And for some reason-- Sam
Adams was just this very cool
historical figure.
He started a revolution,
he was actually a brewer,
and he was the first of the
American founding fathers
to believe in
American independence.
The rest of them
were like, we need
to fix the relationship
with Britain,
we need representation
with the taxation.
Sam Adams was like, fuck them.
We need to be our own country,
we have our own destiny,
we are different, we
need to be Americans.
And he has this wonderful--
his last act was where he
was buried, where his grave is.
And if you-- Sam Adams was a
propagandist, a rabble rouser,
a true revolutionary.
He wasn't an
establishment figure.
He stirred up the people
against the British
and he provoked the British
into the Boston Massacre,
into shooting five
unarmed Americans.
His cousin, John Adams,
who was the lawyer who
defended the British troops.
Sam Adams was the
radical who drew
bright lines and the British
fired on these Americans
and five of them died.
Sam Adams chose to be
buried on Tremont street
on the Freedom Trail in
the Granary Burying Yard
at the bottom.
And if you go through
the graveyard, the rich,
the well-born people
are all at the top.
John Hancock, James
Otis, et cetera.
Ben Franklin's parents.
Sam Adams chose to be
buried at the bottom where
the ordinary people were buried.
And he chose to be-- its
in the right hand corner
at the very bottom--
he chose to be
buried around--
and around him are
five very small gravestones.
Those were the five victims
of the Boston Massacre.
And he chose to be buried
closest to the first man
to die in the cause of American
liberty and independence,
a man named Crispus Attucks
who was a black man,
an African-American.
So next to Sam Adams is
buried an African-American.
And that was, for his time,
that was a very, very powerful
statement.
BRIAN CUSACK: It's still
a very powerful statement.
JIM KOCH: Yep.
BRIAN CUSACK: Really
a powerful statement.
JIM KOCH: 200 years later.
BRIAN CUSACK: We
have a question.
JIM KOCH: Good.
AUDIENCE: So I wasn't
around for the revolution.
JIM KOCH: Well, the craft beer
revolution, you've lived it.
AUDIENCE: But--
JIM KOCH: Many revolutions.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: I was
around for Letraset.
I remember the section of the
Coop that had all the Letrasets
and it was fascinating.
And across the street from
the Coop was the Wursthaus.
JIM KOCH: Yes.
BRIAN CUSACK: And
the Wursthaus was
famous for having 100 beers
or something like this.
JIM KOCH: Yes.
AUDIENCE: They were
famous for having
a long list of beers, none
of which they had in stock.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
OK.
JIM KOCH: And the rest
of which were stale.
AUDIENCE: Details.
Details.
But they were known--
they had their own-- fine,
for the menu of 100 beers.
JIM KOCH: Now a freaking bank.
It was much better as a bar.
AUDIENCE: So they had 100 years
and they were all imported.
JIM KOCH: Yes.
AUDIENCE: They probably
had some local ones.
JIM KOCH: No.
There were no local ones.
AUDIENCE: Not at all.
Maybe.
OK.
JIM KOCH: None.
Zippo.
AUDIENCE: All imported.
Because imported beer, as
we all know, is better.
Right?
This was the--
JIM KOCH: Well--
AUDIENCE: This was
the reputation.
JIM KOCH: Beer is perishable.
Beer is liquid bread.
AUDIENCE: I understand.
JIM KOCH: It lasts for
four or five months.
AUDIENCE: I understand.
But that was the
reputation at the time,
that if you wanted good beer
you had to buy imported beer.
And at the same
time, by the way,
there was entrepreneurship
at that time.
Microsoft, Apple, VisiCalc.
VisiCalc had come out
with its killer app
a few years before you started.
JIM KOCH: I remember.
I actually finally
finished business school
with Dan Bricklin.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JIM KOCH: And Tiny Troll.
He was writing Tiny Troll
two levels up from me.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So this stuff was going on, and
here you are as an entrepreneur
and you say, I want to
start my own business.
And you see VisiCalc
taking off and you
see your ancestor's business
of beer-- American beer--
and everyone knows that only
imported beer is good beer.
Did you think about--
I'm really happy you
did the beer, by the way,
because it's my favorite beer.
But did you think about
high tech as a possibility?
Did you think about other areas
of starting your business?
JIM KOCH: You know, the
quick answer is, no.
Because, the same thing here.
I'm looking around this room and
everybody's smarter than I am.
So don't go into business where
everybody's smarter than you.
I had a client when I was a
consultant who was in the air
conditioning business, and
General Electric was my client,
and the guy who ran their
air conditioning business was
a nuclear engineer.
And we eventually ended
up selling it to Trane.
And the guy who ran Trane
was a nuclear engineer.
I learned from those
guys because they said,
we were nuclear engineers
and everybody else
was smarter than we
were, but then we
got into air
conditioning and nobody
was smarter than we were.
[LAUGHTER]
And they did quite well.
That's why beer has
done well for me.
AUDIENCE: You're
being very modest.
I mean, you were at BCG,
Harvard MBA, et cetera,
so you're doing the
modest show very well.
JIM KOCH: I know what high IQ
looks like and it's not me.
In all humility.
BRIAN CUSACK: Another
question over here, Jim.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So it seems that there's
traditions in the brewing
that it goes from
father to son or father
to grandson and
things like that,
and your recipe is from your
great grandfather you said?
JIM KOCH: Great great.
AUDIENCE: Great great.
So it's kind of a
two-parter, my question.
This is like-- this has
happened a number of times.
For example, Bitter
Brew details what
happened in the
Budweiser family and how
that whole process broke down.
Can you speak about whether
or not anybody in your family
is interested in taking
up the brewing thing,
and similarly, can
you talk about what's
happening in your industry
with consolidation and InBev
and your thoughts about that?
JIM KOCH: OK.
Those are quite different.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I know that they're hard--
JIM KOCH: Let me, OK.
I'll answer them both.
AUDIENCE: I think that the
InBev one is kind of related to
what happened at
Budweiser wite--
JIM KOCH: Yeah.
The gene pool got
to the shallow end.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JIM KOCH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk
about those two things,
if you would, please?
JIM KOCH: OK.
I have four kids and
one of them ended up
as a lawyer-- public defender.
I have three daughters.
So one is a public
defender, a second
is in college in pre-med, wants
to be an orthopedic surgeon
because somebody told her
that orthopedic surgeons get
to play whatever music they want
in the operating room and she
thought that was cruel,
and the other has just
graduated high school.
And then I have a son who I sort
of had this conversation with.
His name's Charlie and
it's like, OK, Charlie,
there's 310 million people in
the United States, one of them
is a seventh generation brewer.
Just one out of
310 million people.
And then happens to be you.
And God bless him.
He said, Dad, you're
such an asshole.
You got to do what
you wanted to do
and I'm going to do
what I want to do.
He loves kids.
He's a school counselor.
And he's happy.
So I'm good.
If it ends there, that's OK.
He got to do what
he wanted to do.
And we'll see.
I have one 18 year old.
We'll see where she ends up.
BRIAN CUSACK: Fingers crossed.
JIM KOCH: Well, you know, I
got to do what I wanted to do
and I've always told my
kids, do what you want to do,
do what makes you happy and
that's going to make me happy.
AUDIENCE: Which is a lot
different than the Budweiser
family, I think.
Part of it's--
JIM KOCH: Well, then you get
to the Busch family, which,
amazing family, amazing
story, four generations
of extraordinary people.
Four out of five isn't bad.
But they're gone.
They're not in the
business anymore.
They got taken over by a bunch
of very, very smart Brazilians.
That's business.
It's competition.
The smart, energetic, talented,
capable, resourceful people
are supposed to win.
This is America.
It's not aristocracy.
You've got to earn it
with every generation.
That's a good thing.
BRIAN CUSACK: Do
you want to comment
on the landscape of the
business, though, of the beer
business, and what does that
mean to you for the next 10
or 20-- personally or your
business-- the next 10
or 20 years?
JIM KOCH: Well, sure.
We have-- the last 10 years,
landscape in American beer
has totally changed.
Today, 90% of the beer
made in the United States
is made by two foreign
owned intergalactic brewing
conglomerates that you wouldn't
even know the names of them
necessarily.
They own everything.
There's one in-- run by
very smart Brazilians out
of Brussels because the tax
rates are low called AB InBev.
There's another one run in
London by very smart South
Africans called SAB--
you wouldn't know what
it is-- SABMiller MolsonCoors.
So all these beers, I mean,
you see them on the shelf
and you see Rolling
Rock or Beck's or Stella
or Goose Island.
They're all owned
by the same company.
by this huge-- and I
could go on with others--
owned by this one big company.
And then on the other side you'd
see Coors or Miller or Redd's
or Molson or Leinenkugel.
They're all owned
by the other one.
They make 90% of the beer
in the United States.
And then the other
10%, 12%, is made
by 5,000 small independent
brewers like Sam
Adams and 5,000 others.
That's the structure
of the beer industry.
BRIAN CUSACK: And
will that 5,000 grow,
shrink, what do you think?
JIM KOCH: I think it
can double to 10,000.
The question would be,
what does that look like?
And that's just a
fundamental issue.
Most of the current
5,000 are essentially
bars with a brewery
in the back, taprooms,
whatever you want to call them.
And that's a very
viable business model
because, as a brewer,
you make a keg of beer,
you can sell it into
the distribution
channels that will put it--
go through a distributor
into a bar.
You get like $100.
Or you can open a
taproom in your brewery,
sell it to people who come
in over the bar for $1,000.
And I know you guys are smart,
so you can figure that one out.
That's a decent--
BRIAN CUSACK: $1,000
is more than $100.
JIM KOCH: $1,000 is better.
BRIAN CUSACK: Yeah.
OK.
Thank you.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: So for me beer
is more about the malt,
and I find most American
microbrews too bitter.
When will the hops tyranny end?
JIM KOCH: Well, people
like what they like
and you have to respect
the authority of people's
own senses.
I'll give you my opinion because
I think both are valuable.
To me, a beautiful
beer is a balance
between the body and
sweetness of the malt
and the spiciness and
bitterness of the hops.
That's the essential
flavor structure of beer.
So to me, you want to taste
both of the brewer's ingredients
in the beer.
Probably the best example I can
give people is Boston Lager.
Which is why it's
been the leading craft
brewer for 30 years.
So at the end of the day,
people want something
that is enjoyable to drink.
When I make beer,
my first criterion
is, is this a pleasure to drink?
Now, we do make
some hoppy beers.
We make some savagely
hoppy beers like Rebel Raw
which is over 100
bitterness units, which
is tongue-scrapingly bitter.
AUDIENCE: Well, Boston Lager
is already too hoppy for me.
JIM KOCH: Oh, my.
All right.
Well, we do make some like
Sam Adams Oktoberfest.
That's very malt forward.
That is a beautiful
malt showcase.
I make a beer called Irish
Red which, again, is very--
in Ireland they can't grow hops
for shit so they-- but they can
do barley.
So Irish and Scotch beers
are very malt forward.
So we make a Scotch Ale which
kind of appears and reappears,
we don't make it all the time.
But I love it and it's
got a smoke malt in it.
So that will come and go.
Irish Red is very malty.
Oh, gosh.
Octoberfest.
Winter Lager, more malt forward.
Has some orange zest some
cinnamon and some fresh ginger
in it.
So there are-- to your point,
the brewer's art encompasses
many, many ingredients.
A brewer can make beer from
anything they can imagine.
I've made beer from maple
syrup, from cranberries,
from grains of paradise,
this West African spice,
from orange zest, lemon
zest, from tamarind,
some of the more controversial.
I made beer from roosters for--
BRIAN CUSACK: It's in the book.
JIM KOCH: It is.
JIM KOCH: In the book.
Had two roosters in the kettle.
There used to be, actually
not that far from here
up in Inman Square,
a place called
Mayflower Poultry that
would give you-- I
went there and got
fresh killed roosters.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JIM KOCH: Is it still there?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Well, they're on
Cambridge Street.
JIM KOCH: OK.
Yeah.
You can get fresh
killed roosters there.
So I got two fresh
killed roosters,
put it in the beer--
feathers, feet and all--
and it was great.
It was called Old Cock
Ale for a friend of mine
who turned 50 when I
thought 50 was really old.
We made beer with 40 pounds
of grilled beef hearts.
I got thousands of
letters from PETA
about that, that beer was
supposed to be vegetarian.
Who cares.
So the brewer's art
encompasses everything.
We're not like wine makers.
Everybody thinks their
role model is wine makers.
And the poor wine maker,
they have one ingredient.
Grapes.
And they have two choices, skins
or no skins and steel or oak.
That's basically the choices
that a wine maker have.
Which, I mean, let's face it.
Red wine pretty much
tastes like red wine.
It's not that easy to
tell the difference.
And the same is-- but
with beer, nobody's
going to mistake cream stout
for Sam Adams or for Rebel IPA.
Nobody's going to mistake
Utopia's for Porch Rocker
or Oktoberfest.
Beer-- the brewer has
all these choices.
A good friend of mine, Sam
Calagione at Dogfish Head,
he said, well, the
poor winemakers,
all they have is the
missionary position.
One ingredient every
night for winemakers.
Missionary,
missionary, missionary.
They just have these grapes.
And what I've added to Sam
is-- and Sam-- we're brewers.
We have the Kama Sutra.
If we can imagine it and we do
a little yoga, we can do it.
BRIAN CUSACK: All right.
We have time for one
more question only,
and I think if we were going in
order it'd come from back here.
JIM KOCH: I'm going to show you
some science while you're here.
This is--
BRIAN CUSACK: We have time
for no more questions.
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JIM KOCH: --IPA.
We replaced carbonation
with nitrogen.
So you get a whole
different experience.
Doesn't even sound the
same as a regular beer.
[SOUND OF OPENING A SODA CAN]
You get all that whoosh and
then you pour it in like this.
And in the glass you get this
amazing theater, this storm
going on, the bubbles-- if
you can see them-- the bubbles
are going down.
You have this sort of cascade
and slowly over 90 seconds,
it will form this
beautiful tight head
of very small bubbles,
which are nitrogen bubbles.
And you probably all
know Boyle's law,
so they're in relative
equilibrium to the atmosphere.
So they're small,
they don't need
to expand because the
atmosphere is like 80% nitrogen.
And that's my little Bill
Nye the Science Guy thing.
BRIAN CUSACK: And that's new?
That's new.
JIM KOCH: Yeah.
Yeah.
What you discover is that
the hidden ingredient
beer is carbon dioxide.
It's a huge flavor impact.
Nitro IPA is 100 BU's,
but because it's nitrogen,
it drinks like 50.
So I guess where
I'm getting to, beer
has been around for
12,000 years but there's
enormous room for reinvention,
for disruption, for innovation.
Just because people have been
doing it for 12,000 years
is no reason to keep
doing it tomorrow.
BRIAN CUSACK: And I think
that's a perfect place to stop.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
JIM KOCH: Cheers.